- Hello.
My name is Shawn Shropshire.
Welcome to Oklahoma.
Take you inside and show you
around my shop.
So this is the anvil
where I do my handwork.
It's one I picked up
off the internet.
Little small anvil in the back.
Another machine I'm working on.
is my surface grinder.
Hope to get it up
and running soon.
Post vise on a big truck rim.
This is my vertical forge
that I use for larger pieces.
It gives a lot more volume.
Obviously,
with the two-burner forge,
I don't have the length that
I need for larger pieces.
This gives me more flexibility
for odd shapes
and larger sizes.
- I'm Jason Brown and I want to
give you a small tour
of my shop here
and some of the things I do.
This is a mining shovel
I built a few years back.
I do a lot of rock hunting.
And I mainly made to sift
sapphires and barrel crystals.
Nothing really too glamorous
here.
This is a two-burner forge
I bought on eBay--good deal.
This is an anvil
that a friend gave me.
Real generous of him.
This is a twisting wrench
that I built,
I mean, this was just a really
old wrench
and then it's...
By far, it gets a lot of use.
This is the coal forge I built.
It has 3/4 inch plate steel
and there's 7018 rods is what
I used to weld it together.
And it comes apart
in three pieces,
so it's real easy to move.
- This is the primary grinder
that I use.
It's a 210 variable speed,
1 1/2 horse.
And this is what I do
most of my work on.
And then I've got another
grinder that's a 110
that I use
for more finishing work.
Most of my hand-sanding is done
here at this table.
My handle scales,
assembly of knives,
guard-fitting, most of that's
done right here.
I've got a knee mill
at this end of the shop
that I use for guard-fitting,
drilling precise holes,
variable drills, my knife
patterns that I've come up with
and several that I've gotten
from friends and other makers.
So sometimes when I need
a break from the knife making,
I'll grab my bow and go outside
and shoot a few targets
to break up the monotony
and get my mind off of things
that might be a problem.
That's my shop.
Thanks for coming and visiting.
Hope to see you soon.
- These hammers are my dad's.
He passed away two years ago
from cancer.
I'm always using something
that he used to own,
and I think he either built it
or had this made, but--
and it has his initials on it
so it's like
my favorite hammer.
I wear my dad's shoes,
basically for good luck.
I wore them on the show
and I'm--
I've worn them every day here.
And then, other than that,
this is--
I wear this arrowhead
that a friend made for me.
It's brought me good luck
so far.
This is my shop.
Thanks for checking it out.